it's on the mount tonight for the padres
he is no no joe
joe musgrove takes the hill 28 year old
making a 16th start
2-2-5 era and eight starts here at petco
park one of the best
in baseball at the home venue opponents
only hitting 176 off java joe
and now trey turner the batter an
all-star for the first time himself
trey turner welcome back
see you later
did max call that one maybe did
schwarber call it
maybe and trey turner hit number 101
home run number 15. well that's how you
put your stamp on your all-star
selection
that was not a cheap home run and he
earned that key right there
john lester eight career starts against
san diego
three and one you can see his mix there
fastball cutter
change up and he also showed a ifa's
curveball last time out
he's got to get ahead with the fastball
strike
three call on the outside edge
lester cutting it back and for him
a perfect pitch and that call could be a
key thing for him tonight
breaking ball a big one for lester and
the strikeout
two in a row lester 41 strikeouts now
in 58 innings
a little bit high and the bases are
loaded
well here's trent grisham well he's had
a good year 10 homers 30 rbis
bouncing ball on the first pitch bell to
lester
gets out of the jam long first inning
for both pitchers the gnats on top early
victor robles gets around that one down
the left field line
not hit that hard long way to go for
tommy pham
second and third with one out john
lester has
28 career runs batted in
lester rips one and it's gonna fall
into center field runners had to hold up
so
gombe scores robles to third and john
lester gets his 29th
career run back at him you know all that
pins hitting over the weekend paid off
1-1 delivery and a punt try up the first
base line
fielded by kronerworth shovel to the
plate not in time
robles with a head first dive past
carratini
on the safety squeeze laid down by
alcides escobar
and the nationals lead three to nothing
leicester to second on the play
soto got a pitch up and out to left
center
grisham trying to get behind the throw
lester scores easily and the nats lead
four-nothing
on juan soto's 38th run batted in and he
sealed the deal quickly
as the eighth net to bat here in the
second swinging a line drive up the
middle base hit center field
rounding third escobar coming home
grisham's throw to the plate is not in
time
josh bell is two for two with a single
to center drives in his 38th run of the
year
and it's now the nationals five and the
padres nothing
he'll pop it up lester grabs it so it's
a one
four double play fielding his position
what what range by the pitcher though
swinging a miss and moscow picks up his
first k of the night
so the bases are filled with friars
again and again it's trent grisham
hey he got hit and that'll score a run
from third comes cornerworth and the
padres are on the board
base is loaded ha sunken coming up
on the ground in a fair ball down the
left field line
bangs off the boxes machado's in here
comes myers
two more runs for the padres and it's
5-3 hot
sun cam drives in a pair
[Applause]
strike three call lester knew it takes
with him the second strike down for joe
musgrove
swinging a man sandy strikes out turner
third strikeout for joe musgrove two
down here in the fourth inning
picked by musgrove he says no
fires to first soto's out
the smile from musgrove 5-3 nets
one out fernando tatis jr
in the air to deep left field for
fernando
second basket to one run game home run
number 27 of the year
for todd pace jr fernando
is electric he's five nothing it's five
four and you must spin it
to shallow left harrison not gonna get
it
thinking two is cronin worth in the
ground zone
look at that all-star go that's a night
for
jon lester as he heads to the dugout
new pitcher kyle mcgowan lying down the
left field long fair ball to the corner
codeword is coming around to tie this
game myers with his double
has tied this game it's five to five
he went around yep he did and checked
with kerwin danley who rings him up
a one two three fifth for joe halfway
through tied at five
o2 pitch
[Applause]
strike three call first strikeout for
craig stamen
one down here in the sixth inning
[Applause]
swinging a miss
and stan is able to strike out hernandez
two down on the sixth inning
back-to-back case for craig stamen
upstairs with the cutter no chance one
out
until now wondersuero a couple of
swinging strikeouts
around the foul papa so josh bell now to
the right side of the plate
oh my left field see
you later and he's two for two against
tim hill
that's back on top bell 12th of the year
second rbi tonight and he's three for
four
one out runner at second and ryan
zimmerman
lined and caught by fernando
you cannot do it any better than that
superhuman
fernando tatis jr up into the air
he's a superhero you never know what
fernando's gonna do
yeah go ahead watch yourself kid now
with two outs it's escobar to try to
drive in that run
escobar lines one to left
and that's gonna bounce into the seats
for an rbi
double and then that's half doubled
their lead here in the eighth well brad
hand
has become one of the most efficient
closers
in the national league and there's the
backdoor breaking ball to end the ball
game
brad hand does it again
19th save 16
in a row